listen since Chris Sims is in Cleveland
getting ready to go to Browns practice
an issue that came up as it relates to
comments from coach Freddie kitchens on
Monday about unnamed sources and leaks
of information and if I find out anybody
on the coaching staff did that they'll
be fired you know Chris and this is a
point that I've made in separate
contexts but let's be real about this a
year ago at this time were we thinking
of Freddie kitchens as a potential head
coach for any NFL team would he have
been on the list of any guys that should
be or could be getting interviews for
head coaching jobs no he he got into the
right place at the right time with Hugh
Jackson fired and Todd hailing the
offensive coordinator also fired
kitchens became the offensive
coordinator did a great job and parlayed
that into the head coaching job but is
he really ready you know we've seen so
many guys who it's almost like they're
groomed to be head coaches Freddie
kitchen just kind of been thrust into it
I I think it's fair to ask whether or
not he's capable and ready to take a
team that has ridiculously high
expectations and get the most out of
them well I mean I guess yes it's fair
to ask but I'm certainly I'm not like
you know what I wanna say discouraged by
these comments that he made that's not
gonna make me feel any different I know
I think you and I may be differ on this
just a little bit you know Freddie
kitchens we talked about it a little the
show he comes from that Bruce Arians
school of coaching I mean yeah what's in
his head he's gonna say it and he let it
be known he was frustrated but I think
with the Bob Wiley comments and he's
trying as we talked about a lot to
change a culture that has been crappy
for a long long time I mean crappy is
nice really and you know it seems like a
lot of guys or a little had to get a
little baby with a lot of things whether
it was the Hugh Jackson era or the years
before that in Cleveland and he's just
trying to set a president set it's not
gonna be that way and he doesn't want to
hear any more of this crap or leaks or
anything like that now going about it
and saying in the media you know I don't
know is that the best way I don't know
that you know certainly up for debate
there but I didn't have a problem with
it yeah I it gave me pause in a game you
can
and it underscored these worries that
that how is he going to respond when
adversity strikes how is he gonna pull
that locker room together can that
locker room get broken apart will he be
too deferential to Baker Mayfield its
perceived in some circles that it was
Mayfield's lobbying privately that
helped Freddie kitchens get the job at a
minimum the relationship between
kitchens in Mayfield that helped make
kitchens get the job and you know now
how do you rein in Baker Mayfield you
let him potentially become bigger than
the team you see a guy that can be
trusted with that manner there's just a
lot of questions here and the ultimate
question is how will this team deal with
losses because they aren't gonna go
sixteen and oh and if they stumble out
of the gates and the folks in Cleveland
think the sky is falling can't Freddie
kitchens be the guy to stabilize it when
things aren't going the way you want
that's what we don't know the answer to
cuz he's never had done that and we've
seen many coaches who when they step
into that bigger job Chris they just
don't have the ability to sell it the
way they need to well yeah yes you're
right but I think he's got charisma I
think he's a real football coach there's
no nonsense no BS I think that's why
guys like Baker Mayfield like him and
the Baker Mayfield likes him I can
guarantee you that a whole bunch of
other guys on the team like him as well
as far as the way he presents himself in
front of the team and players and
everything like that and yeah we don't
have much to go for from right now we
don't know but we do know that he took
over last year as the head coach of the
Cleveland Browns and they became a lot
better instantly I mean he changed the
way they approached the offensive style
of football it was much more successful
that way and they won football games so
you know for his first test okay or he's
had to test right handling the offseason
and these personalities he's got on the
team so far that's been pretty good you
know I know you see a little crack in
the armor with these comments but the
other thing is what he did at the end of
the last year was really his first test
and he took over in a crappy situation
not always easy and he turned the team
around and the vibe of the team totally
around and I think we got to give him
credit for that and I think because of
that he was deserving of being a head
coach here in Cleveland
yeah I agree with that we just need to
see what happens when that is our city
if the Browns don't live up to what we
all expect them to do and I think that's
one of the reasons why he's been trying
to reel those expectations in so it
isn't crippling if they end up two and
four or three and five or something that
would have been regarded is not bad in
past years for the Browns but very bad
this year
hi I'm Mike Tirico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from NBC
Sports